2016 election madness has begun may God
have mercy on all our souls a bloomberg
national poll shows fifty-eight percent
of republicans and independents would
consider supporting senator rand paul in
the GOP primary brand who announced his
presidential bid last week is the
current forerunner of the republican
party at least fifty percent of the same
voters who praised reigns expressed
interest in supporting five other
aspiring candidates including Mike
Huckabee Rick Perry and Mark Rubio
signaling a potentially lengthy
nomination battle alright so we just did
a previous segment where I was defending
Rand Paul a little bit it sounds like
he's in the front at the moment but when
you hear all this stuff and you watch
those names Huckabee like doesn't it all
it seems like a time warp doesn't it
seem like these guys all existing the
time work Marco Rubio he's younger
Latino people seem to dig them but the
rest of them it just seems like
dinosaurs being dug out from Republican
graves yeah and it also speaks to the
fact that I think I mentioned in an
earlier segment that being a politician
is not about your principles or what you
stand for it really are least not a
successful one right being a successful
is a likeability thing its people liking
you and the fact is there isn't a really
strong Republican candidate right now
that's likable they're not likable so
that's where that's why you're seeing
all of this kind of fracturing within
the party of maybe this guy or I could
vote for this guy or this guy or this
guy yeah none of them really embody all
of the characteristics that I think
voters want to what they want to believe
oh this guy can take us and do something
different or this person can do
something different for us so we sort of
want Jesus right like that's what we
seem to really want is this like when
Obama ran the first time it was like he
was everything everyone thought he was
unbelievable I know yeah I know it's
40-something presented but like it felt
like there was this incredible feeling
like this is the the second coming and
we want yes we can hope and change but
do we not really need that do we
actually need someone that maybe isn't
likable but actually wants to hardcore
govern
no his [ __ ] inside out and all that yeah
I highly doubt that the American would
public would ever vote for somebody they
didn't like I feel like that's at the
forefront of everyone's mind like oh
they cool yeah you know like the
Republicans can I have a beer with them
if they can then cool then they're gonna
vote so that is that why this country is
totally screwed that we get more
obsessed like this week with Hillary
having chipotle and did you see the
video there were literally like dozens
of reporters chasing her into chipotle
and everybody was doing articles on what
did she order it was a chicken bowl like
that actually is more important than
what her views on foreign policy or
whatever exactly I think that it my
answer your question me away yeah yeah
that's a problem and it's also the
problem that a lot of people especially
our young the younger generation don't
actively take a role in yes making sure
that the direction that the government
is shaped in cuz now it's it's like the
entertainment interest rates industry
it's a bunch of 60 and 70 year old dudes
all you know jack and their dicks and
saying how great they are and it's the
same idea that keep gets certain getting
circulated is this like the sort of
catch-22 of social media also that like
I love how it connects everybody and
people no more and if there's a
revolution in Egypt we can know about it
and then at the same token like our
politicians all feel like they have to
be on snapchat and Instagram and doing
all the right things and it just makes
it that much faker yeah it does seem
very superficial but to not utilize
social media would be very stupid yeah
you know and I feel like it's important
in making change in spreading awareness
you know etc how much how much can you
guys talk about polls before like we're
22 months out and I know the media's
going crazy I'm in that world my Twitter
stream just in this week because a Rubio
and Rand and and Hillary like I see it
already changing we're already talking
about two years in the future instead of
talking about now which I think it's
that's kind of dangerous no you think
that we stop focusing on there's still
two years of this guy and and two years
of things that are happening now yes but
at the same time that's it's the it's
the problem and the benefit of living in
kind of an instantaneous instant coffee
type world where you know this news
comes in and it's all your attention
goes on to that full throttle for the
entire day and a half and then public
are our
and I'm now over here so it's it's
reflective of that world and everybody
wants to explode things out and new
stories because there's so many sources
for news yeah they have to make things
into news that's why Chipotle yeah yeah
like why am I watching this I don't even
know why I care yeah cuz it doesn't
really matter in the grand scheme of
things but i think it's it's the way we
consume information now so it's just
reflective of that but i do think you
can always find something that is oh
this is the flaw with this and the flaw
with that i think at the end of the day
people just have to like you said stop
looking so much on how pretty or how
cool or how down-to-earth the person
seems and think about their policies and
how that will affect not only you
personally but the people you care about
and the thing the policies that you care
about in your country otherwise you're
[ __ ] i'll try to spin this positive is
something good actually happening here
where we're getting these nonsensical
chipotle things and you know they said
Rand Paul fights with women because he
had one interview that was a little
whatever that we're getting that stuff
out now so maybe as we get a little
closer election it could actually be
about real that you think do you think
that's actually possible and probably
not right yes no I remember the last
election like we were still talking
about binders of women and a ridiculous
things that no one really cares about
people like to focus on this silly
little things which is okay as long as
at the end of the day you're not voting
based off of that do you have a binder
of women let us know in the comments
right now